der lang ersehnte augenblick ist da nur
an und sarah vom vater nach ägypten
entführt sind soeben mit ihrer mutter in
interlaken angekommen
es ist spät nachts um halb zwei mutter
und töchter haben eine beschwerliche
reise hinter sich fünf aufreibende jahre
hat karin traxel um ihre töchter
gekämpft jetzt sind sie wieder zu hause
die erleichterung ist groß kaum
angekommen versucht die familie an die
vergangenheit anzuknüpfen aus der vater
die mädchen nach ägypten verschleppten
waren nur an und sarah zweieinhalb und
vier jahre alt die erinnerung an ihr
zuhause ist verblasst
[Musik]
auf diesen moment haben die großmutter
und die beiden onkel fünf jahre gewartet
[Musik]
karin traxel konnte ihre töchter bereits
vor zwei monaten in ägypten in die arme
schließen musste aber bis heute um die
ausreiseerlaubnis bangen
[Musik]
zwei tage sind seit der ankunft der
mädchen vergangen
karin traxel möchte mit ihren beiden
töchtern die ihnen fremd gewordene
heimat erkunden
sarah die mädchen wurden aus ihrem
gewohnten umfeld gerissen
dass die mutter arabisch spricht hilft
sowohl sarah es auch nur an sind
verunsichert jede auf ihre weise
das ist im moment situation wo sie sich
befinden
auf den neu gekauften trottinett geht es
auf entdeckungsreise
vor dem haus begegnen sie dem großvater
er wohnt in der nachbargemeinde
vor allem aber das schweizer team
sie haben im moment sehr schön
auch die mutter muss sich erst wieder an
die eigenen kinder herantasten
[Musik]
die jungen ist er nach temperament das
ist meine schauen was auch wie schwierig
war es noch etwas erkennt wie sehr ich
denke ich dass sie schlagen was sie aber
sie fuchs sieht ja wohl dennis s leasing
st us stars michael verbringen
wie stoffbeutel sie ist jetzt die ganze
zeit am futterer überall so sie
beschimpften mir eigentlich eher
zufällig jetzt tragen jetzt ist er ja
doch ich du bist und so das muss man
schon das geht einfach nicht hier unter
diesem kulturkreis und warum es gar
nicht nachher dem hab ich hoffe dass sie
ja solche situationen was in einem
natürlich und nachher andere situation
aber das ist ja wie eine trainings
finden so dass sie für meter voran
klick.de
natürlich fragen sie mich das ist klar
und die wand sie das handhaben die
beziehung zum wort ja grundsätzlich in
engstem einiges recht auf mutter und
probiert mit telefonie und selbst einen
rückgang auf dem zweiten mal nicht gott
sofort das limit formel fackler gekriegt
und warum sie die große liebe
die mutter telefoniert
ägypten die heimat ihres ex-mannes
hierhin hat er die gemeinsamen töchter
entführt diese aufnahmen von karen
traxel entstanden vor rund dreieinhalb
jahren um ihren mädchen nahe zu sein zog
die lehrerin von interlaken nach kairo
sie durchlebt gerade einen alptraum
dabei hatte alles so romantisch begonnen
die kultur das laufwerk für andere so
immer wie religiöse fanatiker geht's
nicht
karin taxis odyssee beginnt als das
regionalgericht tun ihrem ex mann das
recht auf ferien mit den kindern in
seinem heimatland zu spricht er und die
kinder kehren nie mehr zurück in ägypten
nimmt sich die mutter einen anwalt doch
nach ägyptischem gesetz hat der vater
keine straftat begangen
auch das amt für auswärtige
angelegenheiten eda kann nichts bewirken
[Musik]
nach langem kampf ein hoffnungsschimmer
karin traxel gewinnt wenigstens eine
tochter zurück als ihr mann ein treffen
mit dem älteren der beiden mädchen
erlaubt taucht sie mit diesem unter
trotz ausnahmezustand die mutter
versucht ihrer älteren tochter ein stück
heile welt zu bieten
[Musik]
doch die jüngere tochter sarah fehlt
kontakte zum geburtstag des
telefonierens probiert was ich derzeit
geburtstag wieder weg so dass sie
schwierige tage ohne väterliche
erlaubnis oder richterliche verfügung
darf die mutter mit nur an nicht
ausreißen was für sie ohne die jüngere
tochter sarah sowieso undenkbar ist zu
diesem zeitpunkt besteht noch hoffnung
perrin traxel erkämpft sogar in ägypten
das alleinige sorgerecht aber die
behörden setzten den entscheid nicht um
es mangelt an villen und dringlichkeit
immer wieder erfährt karin traxel
niederschmetternde rückschläge
[Musik]
in der schweiz unterstützt die
großmutter karin traxel scampia sky
versucht sie karin aufzubauen
im frühling 2016 hat die verzweiflung
ihren höhepunkt erreicht tochter nur an
wurde karin erneut genommen eine von
ihrem ex-mann angeheuerte männer bande
schlug sie nieder und entriss ihr das
kind bekommt was passiert
wenige wochen später kommt es erneut zu
einer wende
karin traxel kehrt in die schweiz zurück
wo ihre tante am flughafen auf sie
wartet auf direktem weg geht es ins
spital karin trucks als mutter wurde am
herzen operiert
ihr kampf kostet nicht nur kraft sondern
auch geld rund eine halbe million
franken haben die praxis bereits
ausgegeben
die reserven sind aufgebraucht karin
traxel bleibt nichts anderes übrig als
in der schweiz zu bleiben um geld zu
verdienen
sie wirkt erschöpft und los zwar wurde
ihr ex mann wegen des überfalls auf sie
erstinstanzlich zu einem jahr gefängnis
verurteilt doch auf kaution frei tauchte
er mit den mädchen unter kein
lebenszeichen mehr
nichts
ein kraut einfach gegen sich das
gestimmt was darunter mitglied unter dem
rand konflikt dass zwei kinder
alle pkw irgendwo ihre honige gesperrt
sie ja wieder ist ein jahr vergangen und
von den kindern fehlt noch immer jede
spur
[Musik]
licht laternen für nur an und sarah die
mutter kämpft mit solidaritätsaktionen
wie dieser gegen das vergessen muss man
die hoffnung begraben
ich glaube aber dass das wird eben da
sind das ist ein fehler wenn es entsteht
der hoffentlich schließt die rennt sie
irgendwo und früher oder später reihte
sich auf rang acht auf das was vorher
nicht geklappt
über zwei jahre hat die mutter nichts
mehr von ihren töchtern gehört bis sich
die ägyptischen behörden im dezember auf
einmal des falles annehmen dann geht es
schnell
weshalb dieser sinneswandel das eda
schweigt und auch die praxis halten sich
bedeckt
der vierfache gesperrt
zumal als villach sogar personell
unheilig es kommen also mit peters und
ägypten gab die krupp truppe zu jeweils
wir jetzt doch für sich so dass man das
müsste umsätze und ihre mädchen sind
wieder da das ist für die familie traxel
die hauptsache auch wenn es
startschwierigkeiten gibt unterschiede
wie essgewohnheiten zum beispiel dass
die großeltern kein arabisch sprechen
erschwert die annäherung zusätzlich im
moment spiele ich ein hier kocht also
das ist chance ist rolle bild war sie
hatte zwei mit das hieße york bevor die
mädchen nach ägypten verschleppt wurden
haben die großeltern oft auf ihre
enkelinnen aufgepasst
gondeln oder david ist das ja nun müssen
sich alle wieder neu kennenlernen
es ist für sie das richtige gemacht
somit sind wieder da wo sie nun aber
muss es wissen und da noch mal
durchstarten
das hat mir schon überlegt ob man dass
das ein neues wort aber schlussantrag
muss man sagen sie hier die bessere
umgebung aus biologisch des landes
besser zeit und dann muss man das glaube
ich hoffe dass im letzten moment schlimm
ich habe die jungs sie sagt noch gar
nicht so viel
ich glaube es geht kräftig vgvs sie
immer zur stelle da war die bakterie
irgendwann mir sehr leid dass ich so
dass das tut mir so leid mir hätte sehr
viel intensiver weil es so hat das soll
möglichkeit gibt dass die sind die
berner landen kann alaba aber der vater
hat es nichts
[Musik]
der onkel kommt mit den kleinen cousins
zu besuch
[Musik]
was frei das muss man sich einfach
unsere familien mit kollegen bislang
noch nicht
ihre töchter sind wieder da diesen kampf
hat karin traxel geworden
der kampf um die gunst der kinder aber
wird noch eine weile dauern